go to work on Lulu smart is a good post
up player he passes out there very well
too
there's table for three good luck the
ball fake gets a man running he has all
day to rise up and he nothing but
bottoms and flippers in possession down
by three Williams yes Lou Williams has
been unstoppable 30 points for Sweetland
that's at 15 of us 30 here in the fourth
quarter bit of 35 to go Tatum fake night
for the first time all-star watch Tatum
here I mean he gets in there he's got
two guys I've not watched a little bit
of a push there but look at this
fadeaway shot man that is tough I think
they call twice is one more thing right
a hound
good look from temple Walker you know
the pump bait ice gets Leonard in the
air and then Harold comes from behind
him now sure did he sidesteps Leonard
for three
rebounded by Morris gets it back out
Morris for three yes big shot by Marcus
Mark J de prata shake loose the dumpster
temple Wolcott not a 3 down to 2 this
Welker with the truck with hitting
and we go to overtime but Kemba doesn't
buy much in your coffee doesn't quit on
this play it all comes in and he gets in
his view late Howell for Leonard Leonard
coming up short gets to the rebound and
a hips just put up into both distant
play power game as we approach 3 minutes
to go a tow to Williams own a hot shot
by Lou Williams like 32 points for Lou
gotta had to bring him in marm can't you
just couldn't move well enough to stay
out there nice throw out but here's
Morris for free my new Williams Tavares
big-time shot by a run Marcus Morris so
the Clippers have taken a four-point
lead and his fifth three-pointer
there's Williams yes Williams continues
his red-hot shooting yeah look at Lou
Williams comes off this pick Jen's I
mean good defense by the other Williams
ran but he just looked lame just got it
got it rolling right now it's Tatum
taunted by Shanna Tatum stretch
[Applause]
[Music]
[ __ ] pump fake and a step through
move I tell you what half minute
remaining
15 on the shot clock Tatum with the step
and slowly it's just 5 for 15 in the
loss this past Tuesday at Houston was
over seven from three and what made that
play Barbie played off the catch he got
the ball was running through it through
to his boots the call we're getting the
official word now there Chabot for three
and the game is tied
Walker potato played by Shannon got of
three doubt of two hairs Tatum
and we go to a second overtime Walker
met by Chabot I wanna vote my Walker
working down
Kemba just drives hard here in a second
to get shimon moving his feet
like you said race of mangoes drops him
off and knocks down that three and
shannon in the backcourt his hannel
going right at williams taking advantage
of his of the height and power smart
with the lead out
dangerous pass broken up recovered by
[Applause]
switch to a palm right there it's Jade
about the drive extra why I like this
move right here guys shopping on him and
he's pulled up and for a jumper earlier
fake the jumper got in there
Harrell came over to contest and he just
powered it up there so unusual other
calls baby this how it puts it down
resume it will be clipper ball just a
powerful move there by montrezl harrell
and he was saying eat me on my header
took it to the rack and threw it down
they like that match at the Clippers
goose Tatum lost the dribble recovered
his he heard two three yes he's been
getting the looks
[Music]